bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite le sommaire de
cette émission ils viennent nous
présenter aftergow le 2e P le groupe
blue Boox aux sonorités pop éctro sera
notre invité en mai l'atelier numérique
à Versailles fait le jeu vidéo au
programme notamment une exposition
rétrospective des consoles et jeux
mythiques qui ont marqué les sorts de ce
divertissement avant-première mondiale
les 14 16 et 17 mai au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline cozy fanchoui
un opéra prologue du célèbre coszy
fantouté de Mozart Nicolas Gervet a
rencontré David Stern le chef
d'orchestre
alors ils sont quatre garçons plein
d'avenir loin d'être des sérials losers
eux ils collectionnent plutôt les
réussites vainqueur du trempelin Fallon
Fest en 2009 finaliste de Pression Live
et du challenge Esprit Musique en 2013
ils font la première partie entre autres
de Puggy ou encore absent minded nous
recevons ce soir deux membres du groupe
Blue Box bonsoir à tous les deux bonsoir
Sylvain à ma droite Maxime à ma gauche
alors vous êtes respectivement batteur
et bassiste du groupe BL Boox qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez déjà nous donner un peu
la gèse l'histoire de Blue Boox comment
est né ce groupe donc on s'est rencontré
c'était au lycée Théo enfin je
connaissais même Théo et Maxime depuis
le alors Théo et Maxime c'est deux
autres membres qui ne sont pas là Théo
le chanteur et Maxime le guitariste
voilà donc j'ai rencontré Tho et Maxime
au
collège on est devenu amis et on a
décidé de de monter un groupe de musique
donc de rock à la base al on va en
parler mais effectivement donc vous éti
trois c'est ça on était trois c'était
donc au lycée et et donc il nous est
venu venu l'envie d'avoir d'avoir un peu
de rythmique dans ce groupe et donc on a
cherché on a cherché sur des sites de
rencontrre de musiciens du coup et on a
trouvé renontre de musiciens ça existe
aussi voilà et on a trouvé on a trouvé
Sylvain comme ça donc voilà le batteur
le batteur donc le le cœur c'est ça cœur
rythmique bou bou alors comment on peut
définir alors justement votre style on
parle les Dr rock c'est ça ouais disons
que le style a pas mal changé mais avec
le nouvel EP after glow on est allé dans
un style un peu plus electropp avant on
faisait un style plus rock on dirait
qu'il y avait plus de guitare c'était un
peu plus incisif d'un point de vue
distorsion et cetera sur les guitares et
là on on avait l'envie de rajouter des
santé des couches euh et qu'est-ce qui
vous a donné justement cette envie
d'évoluer plus vers la pop électro bah
je sais pas on s'est pas vraiment posé
autour d'une table tous les tous les
quatre à se dire bon on va changer style
ou pas c'est à force d'écouter ce style
de musique et on a fait beaucoup de
compos qui allit dans dans plein de sens
différents et on s rendu compte qu'on
avait vraiment envie de faire ça que
c'est un style qu'on appréciait que
nous-même on en écoutait beaucoup c'est
important justement de voilà vous il y a
des choses qui vous plaisent vous avez
aussi envie de les finalement de les
pratiquer de les mettre en scène vous
aussi c'est ça en fait le le style le
style a changé naturellement c'est au
fil des années nos goûts ont changé on a
écouté a écoué d'autres groupes qui étai
qui étaient du coup plus pop et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on s'est naturellement
tourné vers vers ce ce nouveau style de
musique alors vous le disiez sortie du
2e EP after glow donc c'était il y a
très peu de jours là c'était le 28 avril
je propose qu'on regarde tout de suite
un
extrait
la the E
I'm it's hard to
expl
after glow donc de Blue Boox a donc un
EP autoproduit comme le premier c'est ça
c'est ça exactement comme le premier la
seule différence c'est qu'on a eu l'aide
du SMA de monille bretonux qui nous a
aidé à produire en partie
l'enregistrement ce CD donc le service
des musiques amplifiées un petit clin
d'œil donc en effet alors on peut vous
voir sur scène très prochainement parce
que ce sera la batterie de Guill enc le
23 mai et le 31 mai également au café de
la plage à morpa alors comment on l'
entendu ce sont des paroles en anglais
ok pourquoi l'anglais pourquoi ce choix
euh donc principalement parce que c'est
ce qu'on écoutait enfin toutes nos
influences tous les groupes qu'on qu'on
aimait chantit en anglais donc ça
paraissait plus naturel d'écrire en en
anglais c'était c'était un choix
purement artistique d'accord est-ce
qu'il y a des qu'est-ce que disent vos
chansons est-ce qu'il y a des
thématiques qui reviennent des sujets
particulier vous aimez traiter euh bah
souvent euh principalement les des
chansons d'amour parce que ouais c'est
ah ouais c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on
c'est ce qu'on vit et puis c'est c'est
entre guillemets le le plus facile
àpirez de de vos vies ouais c'est ça on
s'inpire obligatoirement un peu de on
met un petit peu de nous dans les
paroles et aussi dans dans les chansons
donc c'est c'est logique que ça parle de
l'amour ou ou d' rêve problématique
actuelle enfin tout ça quoi d'accord
très bien alors comment vous fonctionnez
tous les quatre puisque dans l'écriture
dans la composition est-ce que chacun a
un rôle précis ou pas comment comment
vous faites euh disons que c'est assez
démocratique disons que il y a des votes
il y a des votes il y a beaucoup de
votes beaucoup d'engueulades que pour
pour donner son son opinion et cetera
mais la base de la base c'est vraiment
Maxime le guitariste et Tho le chanteur
qui qui amène une base de morceaux un
guitare voie des fois juste un un petit
Rif et après Maxime cordon le bassiste
et moi-même on on retravaille dessus les
arrangement on donne notre avis sur ce
qui avait été déjà créé et à partir de
là c'est chacun pe rajouter un chacun
rajoute il y a pas de de truc défin en
fait il y a pas de moi parce que je suis
batteur je vais faire la batterie ça
peut être Maxime qui va amener de la
batterie ou ou Théo qui va amener de la
basse et cetera en fait chacun une
complémentarité en fait dans dans le
travail des uns et des autres disons
qu'on est fait pour faire de la musique
tous les quatre ensemble et ça marche
très bien ça marche bien bah oui si
depuis 2007 le groupe est est souousé
effectivement très bien alors vous avez
décidé aussi tous les quatre de mettre
un peu entre parenthèses votre vie
professionnelle vous avez fini chacun
vos études ça c'était un acquis auquel
vous vous teniez et là depuis quelques
mois vous vous consacrez donc
exclusivement à la
musique j'ai envie de vous demander
qu'est-ce qui est important selon vous
là pour évoluer dans le paysage musical
français il y a déjà beaucoup d'autres
groupes qu'est-ce qui est important
qu'est-ce qui fera la différence pour
vous moi disons déjà faire une musique
originale c'est c'est un point vraiment
important et c'est d'avoir une pâte que
quand on écoute une chanson d'un groupe
on puiss se dire ah ça sonne Blue Box ça
sonne un autre groupe çaid voilà c'est
ça qui qui est vraiment quelque chose de
for ça peut être une voix ça peut être
une guitare une façon de composer aussi
ou ou même un style musical à part
entière complètement nouveau après
évidemment on va pas le cacher le fait
de prendre une année sabatique prendre
cette année avant de prendre le le le
monde du travail c'est cétait important
parce que quand on va faire de la
musique d'un point professionnel faut
prendre du temps quoi faut prendre du
temps fa fa donner les moyen de le faire
on aurait pu continuer nos études ou
même commencer à travailler sauf que ça
aurait un peu compliqué les choses donc
ça aura pris plus de temps en fait
plutôt de sortir un EP en un an ça nous
aura peut-être pris 2 ans 3 ans on
aurait du mal à pouvoir organiser
vraiment une une belle tournée donc à un
moment un autre faut faut lâcher prise
et y aller quoi sans réfléchir vous avez
des des inspirations des des groupes
précis qui vraiment vous vous donne
envie de qui sont des exemples ou c'est
assez varié qu' y a des des influences
particulout on écoute énormément de
choses mais mais il y a quelques groupe
qu'on peut qu'on peut peut-être citer
comme breton moi j'aime
beaucoup français il y a Griff Joy qui
sur la scène la scène montantee
française euh après je sais pas si on
peut dire phéniix évidemment de versaill
comme un group proche de versaill
oatoement on nous le ressasse assez
souvent donc que c'est un groupe qui
qu'on aime beaucoup après il y a plein
de petits groupes on écoute vraiment
énormément de choses et surtout des
groupes pas du tout connus en fait on
écoute beaucoup plus de groupes pas
connus que de groupes très très connus
donc ça fait que quand on nous demande
justement quel groupes on aime pour
sortir des tonnes mais c'est des noms
qui sont pas forcément connus du public
en tout cas bon bah donc l'idée c'est
d'aller vous voir sur scène c'est ça
pour se faire son idée pour vous
découvrir donc premièrement le 23 mai à
la batterie à Guille en cour ou alors ou
les deux d'ailleurs le 31 mai au café de
la plage à morpa merci beaucoup à tous
les deux merci euh nous passons
maintenant à un autre sujet parce que
devant l'industrie du cinéma et la
musique il y a le jeu vidéo qui atteint
en 2012 un chiffre d'affaires de près de
60 milliards d'euros alors quels sont
les secrets des jeux et consoles
mythiques qui ont fait son histoire une
rétrospective à découvrir jusqu'au 31
mai à l'atelier numérique de Versailles
des images de Patrick Jacques de
dixm avis aux amateurs de RRO gaming ou
tout simplement au curieux l'atelier
numérique de Versailles rend hommage
jusqu'au 31 mai aux célèbres consoles et
jeux vidéo qui ont marqué les sort de ce
divertissement un mois entier consacré à
ce phénomène de masse qui touche
aujourd'hui près de 25 millions de
français nous avons décidé d'organiser
ce mois du jeu vidéo qui est une forme
d'art une forme de culture très
importante et d'autant plus que et de
plus en plus les scénarios de tous ces
jeux vidéos se rapprochent de plus en
plus du cinéma et même parfois dépasse
le cinéma avec vraiment cette forme
d'art particulière qui est le jeu vidéo
une forme d'art particulière dont le
secteur ultra dynamique ne cesse de
croître depuis plus de 40 ans des
recettes qui lui confèrent la place de
première industrie culturelle en France
et dans le monde devant celle du cinéma
et de la
musique en collaboration avec le musée
du jeu vidéo l'exposition play tretro
met en avant notamment l'évolution des
techniques du graph et du design du
jeu c'est une exposition qui a une
double vocation c'est déjà d'une part de
faire découvrir à ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas ce matériel assez
ancien finalement le jeu vidéo le faire
redécouvrir mais aussi il y a un côté
très interactif qui permet aux gens de
jouer avec ce matériel qu'on retrouve
parfois dans les cartes mais pas du tout
devant une télé ni dans un bar à l'heure
actuelle donc c'est vraiment c double ce
double aspect interactif et découverte
que nous avons voulu mettre en avant
sans oublier peut-être le côté un peu
pédagogique on a voulu on a cherché à le
faire ludique avec de l'interaction
toujours avec des DVD et cetera qui sont
à disposition du public et des cakono
qui expliquent un petit peu l'histoire
mais aussi le jeu vidéo est parfois
critiqué on le connaît pas forcément
bien donc nous on a envie aussi de de
mettre la lumière sur certaines
critiques qui lui ont été faites sur les
préjugés qui qui qui l'ont touché et du
coup voilà c'est ce côté pédagogique un
petit peu le le 3è homme de notre
exposition pour mieux comprendre ce
phénomène atelier démonstration et
conférence débat rythme le mois
d'exposition alors notez également
qu'une conférence débat pour un bon
usage des écrans à destination des
parents aura lieu à l'Hôtel de Ville de
Montini le Bretonneux mardi 13 13 mai
pardon de 20 20h à 22h les inscriptions
sont à réaliser aux coordonnées qui
s'affichent création en avant-première
mondiale au Théâtre de C yeline les 14
16 et 17 mai cozy fchuli un opéra
prologue prélude pardon du célèbre cozy
fantouté de Mozart et Nicolas Gervet a
rencontré le chef d'orchestre David
Stern mozart n'est pas mort erriic
Emmanuel Schmith Nicolas Baker et
jean-iv Ruff ainsi qu'opéra foco l'
ressuscité pour le mettre en scène dans
Kossi fcholi un prologue à Cossi vanouté
le célèbre opéra c'est maintenant c'est
tout de suite c'est David Stern qui nous
en parle et c'est dans le kiosque h
petit sa de
cabri
cherche
t si j'en
se seement pour te
rejoindre je vis avec l'espoir qu'un
jour ton
sourire
RP c'est les personnage quelques années
avant que l'œuvre de Mozart débute
l'idée c'était comme regarder les
personnages de Cos fant autrement et
surtout la relation entre don Alfonso
qui lui
est le le
vieux très am dans dans le Mozart qu'on
connaît qui qui n'aime qui naime plus
les femmes qui complètement amè
vis-à-vis l'histoire de l'amour et et là
c'est en fait ça devient une histoire
d'amour de vrai amour entre Alfonso et
des spina la servante de des de
sœurs
pouronou Nicol qui est compositeur
avec qui s'est très bien écrire pour les
voix qui aussi a
une patine de son dans son écriture qui
est très très facile à écouter mais
c'est c'est pas une musique simple c'est
une musique claire c'est une musique qui
chante et qui parle directement au
public et j'ai trouvé que surtout avec
des jeunes chanteurs que c'était idéal
pour ce choix donc on est allé voir éc
Emmanuel Schmidt et lui le grand amateur
admirateur de mousard il a vraiment pris
le temps pour créer une histoire ire qui
est charmante et aussi lucide et qui qui
a des moments de mélancolie mais qui est
très
touchante le feu le feu
pass S
laond
j'ai demandé à Jean Yv Ruf de faire la
mise en scène c'est quelqu'un que je
connais depuis longtemps et je connais
déjà sa mise en scène de kifant c'est
quelqu'un qui comprend exactement
parfaitement le texte tous les roules
tous les complications à de l'œuvre
c'est-à-dire qu'on a commencer à
travailler avec les jeunes écoliers
comme avec lesquels on travaille t tous
les ans cette fois-ci ils ont commencé
au mois de septembre octobre avec les
cœurs que Nicolas Bakr a écrit et ils
onur ont appris ça par cœur il
aujourd'hui on est loin de la première
mais quand même ils ont bien appris leur
leur roule et c'est un plaisir de de les
entendre et de voir comment il
développent dans moi le sol
de
Dieu
le le
P je voulais des des voix jeunes et j'ai
j'ai choisi vraiment des des tout
nouveau entre 18 et 23 24 ans et ils ont
encore euh c'est la matière importante
mais c'est encore un peu vert dans la
voix c'est ça que je cherchais et puis
avec ces jeunes chanteurs quand on
montrera avec kifan touté de Mozart on
aura les chanteurs plus âgés là il y
aura vraiment un changement de
génération ça sera très très
je je ne remplace
pas ditesmoi est votre
sœur se
prés F bien
vous n'avez pas
honteous
PRU preu
de c'est très haut de
volet je suis très heureux de pouvoir le
faire créer ici à Saint-Quentin en
Eveline et ensuite on va le faire à
Paris au Théâtre des champ lysé et après
on a desés inéressés en Suède en en
Autriche aux
États-Unis en Belgique alors je crois
que ce qui est important avec cette
œuvre c'est qu'il y aura vraiment un
avenir pour cosifanchoué ça sera pas la
dernière fois alors le public de
Saint-Quentin peut dire ah moi je l'ai
entendu pour la première fois quand
c'était ici dans notre théâtre c'est
vraiment tout public euh c'est il y aura
quelque chose pour tous les tous les
jeunes tous les âges on a fait John
Giovanni ici déjà pour tout le public
alors on a la l'habitude ici ici à
Saint-Quentin l'opéra c'est pour tout le
monde et après que si fan chouie on
retrouve une autre artiste qui connaît
la chanson j'ai nommé
Aurélia comme tous les mercredis place
maintenant aux sorties iné au micro
d'éodim moine c'était un super film j'ai
adoré il y avait beaucoup d'humour
c'était très très réaliste les acteurs
il y avait beaucoup de fraîeur qui se
dégageent d'eux donc franchement c'est
un film que je recommande vraiment de de
voir c'était sympa c'était frais c'est
plutôt rigolo et voilà bon c'est pas le
film de tous les temps mais c'est sympa
àer voir quoi très drôle très original
il y a pas mal de les conversations sont
vraiment tordante
euh c'est ouais j'aime bien les
situations en fait c'est pas mal c'est
un très bon film c'est un film éprouvant
remarquablement fait en terme
d'humanité c'est un film qu'il faut
absolument aller voir vraiment poignant
moi je pensais que c très bien fait les
niveau comment dire niveau décor c'est
très bien son tous les personnages
jouent très bien les acteurs sont
formidables bon vers la fin c'est un peu
triste et sinon bah niveau effets
spéciaux il y a rien à dire quoi c'est
magnifique il y a des cou et tout très
sympa je vois pas le temps passer donc
2h1 de film très agréable et on attend
la suite alors cette semaine notre
professionnel du cinéma et Luc Becan
directeur du ciné7 àencour et nous livre
son coup de cœur mon coup de cœur cette
semaine c'est le dernier film de Pierre
Salvadori avec Gustave kven et la Grande
Catherine de neuve donc une tragique com
comme d'habitude un petit peu acide qui
raconte l'histoire d'un type qui plaque
tout plutôt artiste et cetera pour
devenir gardien du meuble qui va
rencontrer une une dame d'un certain âge
qui est plutôt déprimée et va mettre en
nœ une jolie amitié voilà c'est une
comédie dou sa mère à découvrir dans not
salle cette semaine et je voulais en
profiter aussi pour vous signaler deux
événement au mois de mai au ciné 7 le 14
à 14h ainségûté autour du film Linéa
dans le jardin de monie donc sur la
peinture de monnaie avec donc après le
la diffusion du film une animation et un
goûter
et le 18 mai à 14h et 17h entrée libre
c'est gratuit on invite nos notre public
nos spectateurs qui sont nombreux et on
les en remercie à partager avec nous un
moment de convivialité autour de la pour
fêter les 1 ans de la réouverture du
ciné 7 voilà donc c'est un ciné concert
et il faut juste réserver sur notre
ligne téléphonique 01 3051 5615 ou sur
notre adresse mail sin 7 tout en lettre
à toinadou.fr
allez je vous propose à présent d'autres
idées de sorti ses prochains jours alors
tout d'abord si vous avez envie de
produits locaux 100 % fermiers je vous
propose de rencontrer des producteur
fermier du 8 au 11 mai à La Bergerie
Nationale à rambbouillet et si vous avez
envie de musique et de jazz surtout
rendez-vous à Versailles du 10 au 17 mai
pour la 11e édition du Versailles Jazz
Festival un résumé de la programmation
vous est présenté par Marie Molière
membre historique du festival la 11e
édition du festival c'est une édition
qui va durer une semaine donc autour à
la fois d'animation et de concerts
gratuits que de concerts en
salle cette année on a une tête
d'affiche qui est le duo de biril la
graine et Sylvain Luc donc le swing
manouche à
l'honneur on aime bien le swing manouche
dans le l'équipe du festival on essaie
d'en mettre un petit peu chaque année
mais on essaie aussi de mettre du jazz
pour tous les goût donc là cette année
on a des nouveautés on a du jazz vocal
notamment avec le le setê de Christophe
dinglace qui s'appelle le muligan vocal
où là le jazz vocal est à l'honneur
puisqu'on a deux chanteurs brillants sur
des musiques de Jerry muligan on a
également de la musique instrumentale
puisqu'on a le le trio du saxophoniste
Christophe Laborde avec Emmanuel Bex au
clavier et Louis
Moutin également qu'on ne présente plus
ça fait déjà 11 ans que le festival
existe on espère que ça va se poursuivre
encore des années donc on attend le
public nombreux puisque c'est sur lui
qu'on compte pour pour perpétuer ce
festival et voilà notre émission est à
présent terminée on se retrouve mercredi
prochain en direct à 18h30 bonne
semaine y